there's it fun to find this is an
historic day today the national
elections are taking place as everything
shows citizen win the elections with
high presented and now I'm going to vote
Nana that's the one name these are all
visitors all the parties this is the
fascists is the golden dome place is
ours Warren's just a moment it's just
stop in all this process we already have
done there are most crucial part is what
we are about a doodle day after and how
we're going to stay true to our beliefs
yes I work for citizen okay good Missy
now we just came to the component of
series again before i am the other of
course comrades were election monitors
so and we're expecting to have great
results and now we are about to hear the
first exit polls please can you step a
bit just too fast it's so not forever
people follow your poor sucks and
occasionally birthday nigga smell adanya
does then hit fun
Alfie excited and less every blessed
because I'm young umbilical years old
and I have already experienced the huge
wing of the movement of the left I came
quite a you know far away from the other
side of Europe and from Western
countries to support South Tirol because
we hope that this is going to be the
beginning of a domino effect that will
spread into Madrid and then Paris and
then why not Berlin we want to cut
austerity basically in Europe answer is
that is now this victory giving us that
she
tonight we celebrate but tomorrow we
continue struggling for our lives the
future began the hope arrived venceremos
I've been a tortured because everybody
in this town is a self torture torture